they since ranch governor and vice
prison and the Board of Governors
Nanci ugly this evening I'm honored to
be here speaking on behalf of our
Academy president John Bailey who's on a
plane on his way to London to greet new
Academy members tonight we gather not
only to celebrate another milestone in a
contest that first introduced the world
to names like Robert Zemeckis Cary
Fukunaga Trey Parker and Spike Lee but
to March and a movement which through
the example of recent winners like
Patricia Reagan and Patricio Cardozo is
helping yeah absolutely it's helping to
break Hollywood's glass ceiling but
above all we are here to introduce the
world to those who will write the next
chapter in the story that's called film
that's you guys
this year as we have since 1972 we honor
an amazing group of filmmakers and we
can only do it thanks to the
record-breaking nearly 700 Academy
members who served as judges choosing
from fifteen hundred and eighty-two
entries from four hundred schools
yeah after tonight the numbers alone
will tell a story that defies even the
most optimistic predictions of those who
filled the room at the first awards show
45 years 503 winners so to all those
judges from all those years we say thank
you and to all of tonight's winners and
entrance in this year's competition
congratulations
congratulations but remember the Student
Academy Awards is not an inheritance
it's an invitation an invitation to keep
dreaming and discovering learning and
leading and to be that generation that
takes movie magic to new heights of
daring and determination the light of
film doesn't shine automatically we're
counting on all of you to keep it
shining now it's my pleasure to
introduce a pasta student Academy Award
winner and now the chairman of the
Student Academy Awards a writer and
director who has traveled the globe from
India to North Korea to tell stories
that the world needs to see please
welcome Greg healthy Thank You Nancy
these awards are dear to my heart
winning a student academy award opens so
many doors for me so it's a privilege
and an honor to be here celebrating
these filmmakers tonight tonight we
salute these new voices who come from
just down the street to around the world
including winners from China India
Switzerland hungry Mongolia Sweden
Taiwan and France
for each of the winners tonight
I hope that your student academy award
is the first step of many in your
careers and I speak for all of us at the
academy when I say that your journey
thus far inspires us and gives us hope
that you will shape our industry to
reflect the complete mosaic of the world
around us as Nancy mentioned we had more
Academy members than ever participating
in the judging process so I too would
like to extend a personal thank you to
all my fellow Academy members who gave
so much of their time to make this
possible your involvement was
indispensably indispensable especially
with so many entries this year so thank
you for your commitment to supporting
this next generation of filmmakers we
have a fantastic program tonight with
winners in seven categories for us-based
students we have the animation
documentary narrative and alternative
experimental categories for students at
international film schools we have the
International narrative animation and
documentary categories a bronze silver
and gold medal will be awarded in each
category although a gold only a gold
medal will be awarded in the
International Animation international
documentary and alternative experimental
categories and speaking of the awards
I'm excited to point out that tonight's
trophy presenters Alexandra Achaia and
Jordan Rogers are alumni from the
Academy's gold internship program
now it's time to meet our first
presenter to celebrate the winners in
the animation and international
animation categories we are joined by an
extraordinary comedian actor writer and
yes even podcast host who wrote and
starred in the semi-autobiographical
Academy award-nominated film the big
sick you know who I'm talking about and
also stars in Silicon Valley
please welcome Kamal Nanjiani Hey good
evening everyone
hi how's it going when I was a little
boy growing up in Pakistan long before I
came to the United States for college I
would sit at our kitchen table and draw
for hours lost in characters and lands a
million miles away however I was not
very good at drawing
I could only draw a house a flower and a
ninja turtle and only Donatello I don't
know why that's what separates me from
the winners of animated film they can
draw more than that they dream of
faraway places draw them and their
dreams become art that art is animation
combining visual creativity and
imaginative storytelling that takes us
away to invented worlds and transforming
pictures and pixels into heroes and hero
ins as real as any in the real world
let's get to know them better and let
their art speak for itself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow you guys are still in school
I feel very inadequate beautiful the
bronze medal winner for animation is
either Shukla for regifter Ringling
College of Art and Design
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
it is truly an honor to be here I would
like to thank the Academy for
recognizing this film amongst the work
of such a talented diverse and inspiring
group of filmmakers at the beginning of
last year I wasn't really sure of what I
was doing or where I was going with my
senior film all I had was the word we
gifted and a desire to make something
special I owe it to my teacher
Paul Downs for helping me develop this
story and Shawn McLaughlin for helping
me realize it a lot of blood sweat and
tears went into this film but I will
never forget the first time I sat with
an audience and saw it on the big screen
it was the most amazing feel feeling and
will remain a constant reminder of why
we puts why we put so much of ourselves
into this medium I would like to thank
my peers at Ringling for always having
my back a huge thanks to my composer and
sound designer
Valentina Ford lastly I would like to
dedicate this award to my eye and other
special thanks to my parents and the
rest of the shocked Lockland for their
constant love and support thank you
[Applause]
I don't even know where you start making
something like that if you needed Ninja
Turtle drawn for your next thing I'm
around the silver medal winner for
animation is you you
she made Daisy the University of
Southern California
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone is it honor to be here too
and at first I want to thank you my
family my uncle who sent me here and
supports me far away from Taiwan that a
time and my and Tamas my boyfriend my
composure and cooperate a story with me
and be there for three years when I was
in u.s. yeah and eating John Johnny T
who would make the sounds for many of my
films together and this the USA my
mentor Sheila's of bien and animus a
broker and Cathy Christine and KZ is
like a lot of faculties in urine c is
for the first reported through this film
and all those demotius studios i intern
in LA which is really helpful for me to
develop this film and all my friends who
is like far away from taiwan does their
work I keep in touch with me in a social
media yeah and of course the ectopy
member foreign is great to where you got
for us and it would be a big staff word
movie forward to the morn the
independence thank you
the gold medal winner in animation is
raccoon and delight by Hanna Kim
California Institute of the Arts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I will try to make this under two
minutes first of all thank you to the
Academy Thank You Sean Hector and the
team for a wonderful week and I'd like
to thank my sound designer Lauren comer
who responded to my cry of health email
and really bringing the film to life I'd
like to thank my mom and dad for their
everlasting support and my mom who's
here tonight my mom gave me so many
children's books for me to read when I
was a little kid and those books ended
up being my main inspiration and reason
to make this film and I'd like to thank
her for giving me all this inspiration
after all these years and I'd like to
thank the faculty at Cal arts especially
my film workshop instructor Frank Krauss
and my mentor Andrew Bach for letting me
create whatever story I wanted to make
and they saw the importance of letting
the students be the creators of their
own films and supported the beginning to
the very end of making this film and
lastly to my dearest friends some of
them are here tonight not only are you
my classmates at school but you were
also the best and Onex honest critics
that I could ever ask for I thank you
for teaching me to have nerves of steel
when I ever wanted to give up and
somehow you'll find the recording of
this video later to make fun of me for
the rest of the school year I love you
guys and thank you thank you so much for
your
[Applause]
this is the second year we featured the
category of International Animation but
I can assure you it is no sophomore
slump we have a single medal winner with
a message that knows no borders and
speaks a universal language
determination and resilience a green
bird lays its very first egg it will do
everything it takes to make it hatch
[Music]
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba ba-ba-ba by yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that's beautiful
maybe in the sequel a ninja turtle lays
an egg and will do everything Donatello
can to make it hatch please welcome this
year is gold medal winner in the
International Animation category from
the Mopa and all France the artist who
created the green bird Pierre / very
Maximilian bushwa marine go alar re
nanine Duke and Quinton Dubois
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
looks like we don't have quite enough
[Music]
Det
[Music]
well it'll be crazy
thank you we want to take the
opportunity tonight thanks to the
Academy to speak about something really
important to us as you can imagine we
worked really hard spend a lot of spend
a lot of time and we think that we had a
lot of luck make by making this
impossible but for us there is something
much more important than work and luck
and much more precious and rare and it's
goodwill the goodwill from all the
people close to us the people who help
us without demanding anything in return
the kindness in people eyes and people
without which for which for us as not to
be only about filmmaking it's what makes
people trust in themselves be themselves
and for us it's the proof that you can
go ahead and do something good
so it's why with my team we want to
thank the Academy first of all for all
the week and for this huge award we want
to thank all the teachers from the
school want to thank the school all the
persons who believed in us and in an
outside school we would like to thank
France wiser from European Maha lavash
the composer and the voice of the bird
and we would like to just thanks
individually some guys so I would like
to thank my love and all the all my team
my crew my parents Apollonia see and I
put my two little brothers luego an ego
will be here in next year a girlfriend
and Lisa my grandparents my cuisine and
all my friends from Andre from Al from
London from Paris
hi I would like to thank my parents my
dad and a big house to my mom who is not
here anymore
in this world but to whom I owe
everything and I would like to thank my
brother-in-law and pull in all my family
who supported me for for a long time and
some of them are here tonight and I'm
really grateful wanting my love and my
Owen mode my best friends and all of my
friends who supported me since the
beginning Sidonie and my amazing crew
here yes thanks
so I would like to thank my my family my
parents my brother and my sister we like
to thank Elsa with a person real
important to me I love her
and thank to consume every now and David
the person I respect the most
and thanks to my classmates thanks to
all the people who supported me and who
believed in me from the for the game and
this means a lot to me
hi I would like I'm sorry for my French
I would like to thank my parents for
their support my own my love which is
here tonight and of course my team
because it was amazing thank you so high
I'm gonna make this quick to rub this up
but I really want to take my family and
friends of course especially my mom
who's here tonight I would like to thank
my thanks my best friend EDI even though
she's all over the world you're always
here for me so I know you're here with
me tonight I would also like to thank
all of the people had that helped me
especially Elise Clothilde and
especially the Bashar Lou cabin when
Alex you know you're here and I love you
guys
thanks everyone
oh there's more of me sorry that was
amazing you know what I did in college I
still street signs once we all have to
find things to be proud of you know and
now to present this year's winners for
international narrative and alternative
experimental someone whose name was
first announced on this very stage of
the student Academy award-winner herself
she has walked in your shoes after a
childhood and career in journalism at
home in Mexico
she'll direct she directed two
award-winning short films as a student
at Columbia she is an artist and
director whose first major film under
the same moon about the experience of
undocumented immigrants captured our
consciousness
please welcome Patricia Regan
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much oh my god
I'm supposed to read but I want to thank
Nancy there and a lot of nice people
here the artists behind these years
international narrative films come from
different countries and speak different
languages and their short films tell
different stories and are from different
places but they all speak in the
universal language of human spirit
whether it's a story of grief and duty
as a wife confronts her husband's dead
center on early onset Alzheimers a story
of with silence and positivity in a
war-torn city under siege or a
refreshingly unpredictable thriller
marrying green satire with teen eyes and
the pressures of Fame these films
couldn't be more different
except for that common strand of DNA
that we call artistic authenticity it's
time to get to know these years winners
[Music]
this is gonna Jack avoided me a little
girl
[Music]
there was such a going back
[Music]
cause of important environment crystal
Austin even ticketed I do
you can make this concede on a personal
portrait of a commissary or you can
assume
[Music]
[Music]
Vicki Lawrence in a filmer Deborah metal
band the laughs okay welcome Nutella new
video and the heart Union gonna get
ready with me video for it go subscribe
I get ready to die the first are so many
ideas are immersive say hey to work till
our machine like it's nothing from me
yesterday the same coming to Canada
already exact thank you what for some
helps the better [ __ ] hugs thought it
leads same Palace oh hey that Allosaurus
character what they they okay in fact
the not in a friendly don't go out now
compliments of Lotus King Cole apartment
blue delete some some does not answer I
was so far
Vincent
[Music]
kiss kiss from analyst
[Music]
the bronze medal winner for
international narrative is a siege by
east van kovash
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello I am here too okay
we wanted to make a story about how to
maintain our self-esteem our dignity and
humanity during war times when I was in
survival it was a fantastic thing when I
met those women there who had beautiful
stories inspiring stories so I really
want you to dedicate this award to them
because I think they are true heroes I'm
very grateful to the Academy to to be
here and experience this whole week and
that they found our film work for this
amazing honor I would like to thank to
Sean Hector
Julia Devon and all you guys who made
this week possible and to meet all those
young devoted and talented directors who
will make fantastic things in the future
I'm sure about that also I'm very proud
to represent hungry and hungry and
filmmaking here tonight so I want to
thank to the Hungarian National Film
Fund to support us and also the
University of Theatre and film arts and
all the teachers there my lead teachers
ildikó an EOD nurse and Ottilia Janish
also my cast also outside school
teachers or mentors Eastern saw and
Alexander managed my cast million a Long
Beach ready to pitch not pitch in our
Jory Laszlo cassock and of course
weather on abortion which without her
talent this film would be wouldn't be
the same I would like to thank to my
fantastic crew my producers Tasha Tasha
Gabbar OSHA monica Mitch Norah a foodie
my line producer country she didn t know
my screenwriter Gaston you come on my
DOP Davina Zoltan my later reduce capita
my sound designer Gabor balázs
my production designer last all right
costume designer you reaching courage in
the first ad result on your way and
please allow me to thank to to my lover
she who is here tonight for supporting
me during the years of filmmaking and
also my mother who is here tonight too
and I would like to thank her too
taught me how to fight for in life how
to fight for my dreams to become a
filmmaker so I think this is the
ultimate proof for her that it was good
to not become a lawyer and start to
pursue my dreams so academia thank you
for that - thank you
[Applause]
and the silver medal winner for
international narrative is Lisa
Gerst Zurich University of the art
almost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening everybody
I'm trying to enjoy this and not getting
a heart attack at the same time so when
I was younger I used to think that
making films was some kind of a utopian
dream of mine because films were
probably made by some people you know
somewhere in the United States or
whatever I couldn't have imagined to
have the chance to make such an
incredible journey with my own film one
day this wasn't only possible because I
started to believe in the importance of
making films but also because a lot of
people believed in me
many people have put all their energy in
this film first I would like to
introduce part of my crew who is here
with me tonight
so this filippo gonna be the producer of
Audion I should all get the actress
unfortunately the second actor Michael
manchanda can't be here tonight with us
and I want to thank both of you for your
unbelievable work and your trust in me
not only I am happy that we made this
film together but I'm also grateful that
the two of you became my friends special
thanks to my whole crew and cast to
everybody who helped us out in Italy and
to the Zurich University of the Arts
especially to you Philip Tron I can't
even say everything I want to thank you
for I would not be standing here without
the love and support of my family - and
my close friends especially I want to
thank my mom because you are always
supporting and loving me no matter what
I do and my dad because you always
remind me to make use of my imagination
because it is the greatest gift
we made this film that is a story about
someone who no longer functions in our
society the way he is supposed to and
about how he should find a way to treat
and respect those people it is a story
about caring for each other and feeling
responsible for two more week and that's
why my deepest gratitude goes out to the
Academy and its members for honoring our
film with the student Academy Award
finally my thanks goes to show Hector
and their team and to all the film
makers I've met in this past and very
inspiring week and I'm proud to be in
this competition with such talented
filmmakers so congratulations to all of
you and International narrative category
is for Jonathan Adler get ready with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much thank you so much to
the Academy we're so grateful for this
I brought my crew here writers among the
herd oxen a Grimm producer you
understand GP cinematographer Nia a
spell also there are four students
Robert Krantz editor and all sound
designer
abolutely post production coordinator
and Andrea's um composer and we want to
thank the rest of the team and the
actors champion Miriam and all the
others and I want to thank my teacher
ylva Gustafson and my mentor Tomas
Alfredson and everybody else at the
Stockholm University of the Arts and I
want to thank my mom and dad and my
brothers are on and you will thanks to
them I grew up watching films and that's
the way we all grew up and that's the
way we learned about the world by
watching films and lots of them were
from here in Hollywood and we made this
film to beg together based on our own
experiences of the pains of growing up
but also film about what it's like to
grow up today since the introduction of
social media the way we talk to each
other the way we communicate the way we
influence each other the way we learn
about the world has changed
and cinema should be here to reflect
that and that's why we worked so hard
for more than a year to tell this story
and that's why we're so so thankful and
happy and grateful to the Academy for
being here and for giving us this award
thank you so much
[Applause]
I am excited to introduce our next
winner someone whose promise and
potential stands out from the crowd even
among a crowd that stands out so much on
its own from Florida State University
she's a winner in that groundbreaking
category sometimes referred to as
experimental alternative films which
challenge traditional cinematic
boundaries
prepare yourself for a cinematic
experience that combines the exploration
of documentary with the playfulness of
animation that springs to life from one
young director who brings it all to the
screen in her own unique style take a
look
please welcome the winner for the
alternative experimental category from
Florida State University University
shiet the map
[Music]
oh thank you so since the young age I
always kind of lived in my imagination
and any chance I could get I would
escape the real world as I preferred
that better however when you get older
you're forced to stay in the real world
and you have to leave that part of your
childhood behind but as I got older I
realized that filmmaking could be the
part could be the medium where I relive
my childhood fantasies and that being
said I'd like to thank the Academy Shaun
and Hector for acknowledging my hard
work and believing in me
it's such an honor I'd like to thank my
wonderful parents mom and pop and my
brother Tristan for always being there
and always encouraging me to be myself
I'd like to thank my two incredible and
talented team members Anisha Gupta and
Gina Hernandez for all their hard work
in this film it simply could have not
done it could have not been done without
them I'd like to thank my family the
brown family in the demand family for
again always being there and supporting
me as well as my incredible friends back
at school I'd like to thank the Florida
State College motion picture arts
faculty and staff who supported me and
encouraged me on this project thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
amount to percent winners for
documentary films please welcome an
oscar-nominated film maker who has
defined barrier-breaking work in this
general that compels us to wrestle with
reality to face facts the real kind and
not the alternative version that
distract and distort a longtime leader
of the documentary branch and former
member of the Academy's Board of
Governors a pioneer in his field who
widened the lens of the camera to
include the chinese-american immigrant
story and bring back America's gaze
history out of the shadows and into the
light please welcome our third
[Music]
good-evening documentaries they inspire
and incite anger and antagonize they
make us think and they make us cry but
most powerfully they make you scare
because they put a human face on all the
issues around us the world in which we
must never turn away even when turning
away might be tempting tonight's winners
domestic and international take us
inside stories the growing needs to see
from the determined doctor who travels a
hundred miles a day in Mongolia to heal
the sick
comfort to dying and bring new life into
the world
to the grandson who forces his
grandmother to confront a long buried
past from world war ii to the overlooked
story of dust in the wind that sustains
and kills at the same time and humanity
of two physically disabled women who
live learn and love as they navigate to
physical challenges there is a single
winner in the category of International
Documentary let's take a look at her
work she is the backbone of the
Mongolian Health Service who travels
hundreds of kilometres in a single day
provide medical care to 1,600 nomadic
families in the desert
[Music]
only one person who knows every single
one of them is a nomadic
we're new routines at hours over dr.
relief features a target with sustained
50s with Nehru today today in
citizenship a journalist
[Music]
please welcome this year's gold medal
winner for International Documentary
from the University of Hertfordshire
Mart birra for pneumatic aqua
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after glass of wine enjoyed good evening
ladies and gentlemen it's my great
privilege to be here all of you tonight
I'm here with my husband who produced
the film we are truly honored to be the
first Mongolians receiving this
prestigious award
I had my MA degree at age of 45 is
firmly enough the same ages student
Academy Awards I really believed it's a
good sign I was right and here today my
daughters are studying at University now
I wanted to have an MA degree before
them to show my children if you have a
wish in ambition you can achieve your
dream whatever you eat as a Mongolian
and grow up in the Gobi I have always
had a burning ambition to introduce the
mesmerizing in harmonic way of nomadic
culture to the world a massive thank you
to the Academy for recognizing honoring
my work and give me the opportunity to
bring Mongolian culture to the world
a huge thank you to my teachers and
classmates of University of
Hertfordshire raucous must have thank
you to my man that my husband my family
my wonderful team in crew the friends
who always believed in me
supported all through all my long in
emotional journey
you know enormous thank you to the
nomadic doctor is not alone in all the
people of the village on the shelf for
sharing your beautiful story with us my
teacher director butter who's in heaven
now once told me that if you want to be
filmmaker
you better have a great knowledge about
everything exists on the world and
always must chain yourself today with
the truth I was this was the key lesson
I have been trying to follow I will say
some words in Mongolian insolence to
human issues in mangas of semen wrong
should be dishonest promised I have to
show trust your feeling in keep
enlightening to people thank you very
much have a great
this award is dedicated to my dad and
now I'd look at the extraordinary
efforts of this year's winners from
right here at home Femi Solis 12 shears
everybody service kushikatsu fair he's a
bunny feet from why are you sleep or DJ
basket only partly on it let's make it
with him
upon Suraj evening no magic white
relations which together each which were
exiting undocumented soul of the human
immortality to serve
[Music]
when was the last time you thought about
dust
[Music]
[Music]
maybe you think it's unremarkable
uninteresting
but what if I told you it can travel
thousands of miles
[Music]
sustained life
[Music]
and even be deadly
[Music]
[Music]
and after I got sick it didn't occur to
me that this is gonna change my life
until probably the meds started wearing
off and that's when it started hitting
me thinking oh gosh what happened my
life is gonna be completely different
it's one thing to become disabled in
life and it's another thing to have
experienced it your entire way fricking
anvil could fall out of the sky and boom
you are now a disabled person welcome
[Music]
the bronze winner for documentary is
that's rising Loren Schwartzman in the
University of California
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much this is an incredible
honor especially to be included amongst
the other incredible student filmmakers
the idea for this film was sparked when
someone told me that dust from the
Sahara Desert blows across the ocean and
fertilizes the Amazon rainforest and so
without this dust the Amazon could not
exist and I thought that was one of the
most beautiful things I'd ever heard and
the more I delved into the dust the more
interconnectedness I discovered a web
including human health ecosystem health
and climate change as John Muir writes
when we try to pick out anything by
itself we find it hitched to everything
in the universe but we're in danger of
forgetting or just outright denying this
interconnectedness and yet no matter how
many walls we erect or distinctions we
make to divide ourselves from each other
and from the natural world our lives and
our fates remain entwined
I hope films like this one can be a part
of the movement to act with this
interconnectedness in mind I'd like to
thank my friends and family for
supporting me through the making of this
film I'd like to thank my classmates
staff and instructors from the UC
Berkeley Graduate School of Journalism
including Spencer naka Socko John ELLs
Mike Shen Mark Shapiro and Chris O'Day
thank you to the people featured in the
film who had the courage to be in front
of the camera including Rob and Wendy
Purdy who shared their personal story
and the scientists and doctors who
shared their incredible work - my co
cinematographer Raphael Roy who's here
tonight and to the numerous other crew
and collaborators without whom this film
would not be possible you know who you
are and I'm so grateful to you
lastly thank you to the Academy for
recognizing the efforts of myself and my
team with this incredible honor thank
you
and it's super meta winner for
documentary is love and loss even gangly
from the University
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you everyone for coming out
tonight seems like everybody brought
their little piece of paper for their
speech so I hope I won't forget what I'm
gonna say so first I want to say
congratulations to everyone every winner
here the finalists and the
semi-finalists of this year's Student
Academy Award
you guys are so amazingly creative and
so amazingly inspiring so I'm just so
honored to be among you guys and
learning so much from you thank you so
10 years ago when I first had my first
step on this soil I got very
disappointed because I didn't see too
many skycrapers like I have seen in
second city so I thought this is another
real United States but ten years later I
am standing here feeling excited and
surreal but most importantly inspired
being the first-generation immigrant in
this country is hard but being a
filmmaker is even harder so my journey
of becoming a filmmaker has been
challenging but rather saying full and
grateful so I'm gonna really use this
time to thank a lot of people so I will
try my best to make it short so first I
want to thank my team right here my
wonderful crew my producers Stephanie
Stephanie Hermia
my editors Sharon and Adam who's not
here and my DP Patrick and my two
wonderful soundy and mixer
Audrey and Davy and also one and the
only composer Andy
they have been so supportive of me when
I even lost facing myself and I couldn't
have asked for better team than them and
also I want to thank all my faculty
support also here today Cade Amanda Lisa
Richard you guys not only the amazing
documentary filmmakers but they have
been the wonderful teacher who spent
hours in the lab with me literally
making the film with us so I think
that's the best example of being teacher
so thank you guys and also I wanted to
thank the two women in my film
Nicole Evans and her husband I mean her
husband's not a female but there'll be a
lovely couple in the movie and they have
been so inspiring and also Karin Crispo
who's not here today she's actually
under going through some surgical
operation but because of these women
they have made me a better human being
they have taught me the definition of
strength persistence and love so thank
you guys
and I would really make a short so and
also I just have to thank my family
first my parents I have to say you know
they they told me everything you know to
be your daughter and you know how much
didn't disappoint them you know ten
years ago they've left everything in
China and came here for my education for
my future so mom and dad I love you and
thank you so much and of course my my
husband and who flew in this morning
three years ago in the same theatre that
was the first time we were here and
we're not dating yet you know he was
just having a crush on me but we were
here and I saw the winner of that year I
was like you know can I be one of them
one day he's like yeah you're gonna make
it and now I'm here so thank you and
thank you for being my love as well I
think he might friends who have given
you their cultures and best literally in
the past few months days I've been
crashing their couches and beds and for
free so thank you guys and lastly I want
to thank the Academy when I was a little
girl in China I could never imagine I
was saying those exact words today but I
am saying it right now and say thank you
to the Academy thank you after thanking
Sean Thank You Randy the you know
everyone now who have made this in
events so amazingly for us and lastly I
just want to sing to all the filmmakers
out who I have spent this past week with
the you know with they have inspired me
so much not only making me a better
person but also better storyteller so
thank you guys all for coming out
supporting us thank you
okay Oh oops
shut the gold winner for a documentary
is well you guessed it and then an eddy
dated life by Matthew fall from New York
University
[Music]
okay I would like to thank the Academy
in its members and my fellow winners for
this amazing journey this moment will
stay forever with me thank you
as some of you have seen in my
documentary my grandmother is a tough
woman she might be called stubborn
how to reach but to me she's a real
world model making this documentary with
her I will discover someone courageous
funny and caring she agreed to open
herself not only to me but to the world
in a moment when the extreme right is
rising again in Europe and in the u.s. I
encourage you to think about who you are
right now and think about how everything
you have experienced in the past as for
who you are now my grandmother was
traumatized separated from her mother
ashamed of her immigrant roots scared of
being Jewish she built a new identity to
fit in a society that typically doesn't
like people on the margins she kept a
secret from her loved ones fought for
her carrier as a woman yes her story my
story is also your story be proud of who
you are of where you come from and do
not let anyone take that away from you
and your family
[Applause]
I just want to tell her that you know I
love her I'm really proud of her and
relieved that today I know that deep
inside she's at peace with who she's I
would like to thank my parents who must
still be trying to figure out how to
stream this ceremony hi mom and dad
my friends my professors at NYU Marcia
Rock Justin Johnson aviva slesin and
most importantly the man without whom
none of this would have been possible
the love of my life John Freeman thank
you
the future of documentaries is so bright
what a relief
congratulations to auto-doc my winners
you know I'm a dad of a teenage son and
it's been really hard being a cool dad
lately unfortunately just nice to
scrutinise and hopefully he's home doing
his homework but I think he you think I
was pretty cool because I get to
introduce the next presenter to present
this year's winners for narrative films
a producer a screenwriter production
designer and award-winning director
whose creative journey has taken us to
places where vampires roam and wolves
run through enchanted woods in search of
a Berlitz and snacks the director of
Twilight Red Riding Hood Lords of
Dogtown and yep coming with Bala the
fabulous and very cool Catherine
Hardwicke
[Music]
hey everybody um this year's narrative
film winners span the globe but bring us
right back home to powerful instincts we
can all relate to feelings of family
love loss and redemption they take us up
close and personal to live the horrors
of modern-day slavery and the shadowy
underworld of child trafficking in Haiti
they take us back in time to relive the
brutality of a communist revolution in
Cuba through the eyes of children whose
lives and family are torn asunder they
struggle to show that they don't know
finnstrom they show the struggle of a
girl in rural China pressured into an
arranged marriage with an older man
she's never met now let's take a look at
this year's winners
[Music]
Iannetta convolution there said
voluntary a second birthday obligatoria
the a seller will show you combine a rom
okay rocky sent out he'd be Mindy Kaling
engraving
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Teesha
i lo
Keisha really
[Music]
it makes his people
Cina
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the man jungle camp is a true family you
could agree upon John since you shall
share yourself young man Jordanna had a
Sherpa I realize as you tell you
cooperate for the demuccio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow amazing beautiful then let's see the
bronze medal winner for narrative film
is as esta as to Cuba this is your Cuba
[Music]
Chapman University
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um thank you so much to the Academy
again for honoring our film this is our
some of our incredible crew just a small
part but before I get too young I want
to say a few things first of all thank
you to all the nominees it's such an
honor to be just numbered amongst you
guys they're all incredible filmmakers
thank you to to Randy and and Sean and
Hector who who put together an
incredible week for us truly the best
part maybe one of the best parts of this
experience is just this week in meeting
all these filmmakers so thank you I'm
here by the grace of God and because my
family and they've given me the greatest
gift that I've ever experienced in my
life which is love so to all of them
Peter Lee's uncle Johnny mom and dad
thank you for loving me so well
this film is inspired by my father it's
his story of coming from Cuba to Miami
as a boy during the Communist revolution
in Cuba and he was won over over 14,000
children that experienced this and being
able to to really kind of make this film
with you has been one of the greatest
joys of my life so far so thank you
so this is our team a writer can't be
here he's about to his wife about to
have a baby but I think he might be
watching
so yeah congratulations to him but thank
you to him for writing an incredible
script an amazing blueprint for really
being just an incredible collaborator
and filmmaker this is our producer John
sage we shot the film in Puerto Rico
which is incredible feat and he made it
he made it a really hard job look look
really easy this is our cinematographer
Trevor Roach our assistant editor Jun
ndit Chris one of our editors Sean our
sound designer Carlos our our composer
who's both his parents also were
experienced operation Feathertop on and
so it was an honor to work with him on
this
Ramin our other editor and my lenka
Dennis our executive producer so we also
shot the film in Puerto Rico and the the
rest of the crew and cast can't be here
but to everyone in Puerto Rico who is
watching especially our incredible
actors now woody Steele amber Roy he
said Bella everyone thank you for for
welcoming us into your home and making
us feel like like a family truly was an
incredible experience to shoot their
before and after the hurricane there's
an incredible talent there so if you
guys ever get the chance to go to Puerto
Rico make films in Puerto Rico it's
incredible
I still got a lot of people with things
so very think thank you to Chapman
University to all my fellow students
classmates are incredible teachers my
thesis adviser Rachel Goldberg thank you
for your patience
- Andy Lane and Bill Crower and Android
Finch and so many other people who are
here Johnny Jensen thank you thank you
my a couple more things we kick-started
this film so to all the people who
donated to this film this film would not
be possible without you and if you watch
this or see this at some point no matter
what you gave to us thank you so much
for your for your gift
and lastly yeah Jeff speaking thinking a
lot about gratitude just to be able to
have this opportunity and to share this
with so many great people and and in
this process I talked to my father a lot
about his experience but was also able
to sit down with a lot of other federal
funning who went through this and they
were vulnerable enough and and gracious
enough to sit down with me and share can
relive really their experience so to all
of those people to the Cuban community
to the federal bank community it's an
honor to be up here and put your story
on the screen and this this is for you
guys so thank you
so the silver medal winner for narrative
film is Lalo's house by Kelly Hoey
University of Southern California
[Music]
[Applause]
well my passing crew please come up run
run run run run and read I want you up
here with me please this took a village
as many of you know it takes a village
to make a film like this and I first
want to say praise God ten year journey
for me almost ten years almost a decade
I caught wind of a an orphanage that was
posing as a Catholic orphanage where the
the nun was allowing foreign men to come
in and sleep with the children and I
have taken years as my parents know
going back and forth investigating this
and then I took that footage and it got
me into USC and was at USC where I was
encouraged by friends and faculty to
turn it into a fiction narrative film
and it this is Lalo's house and I want
to say one thing that is so moving to me
is that to all the students who are here
today can I hear you if you're a student
in school right now I sat in those same
seats last year and I watched the
phenomenal films that the Academy has
allowed us to - given us a platform to
be able to show our art and I want to
see you up here next year okay
I am gonna go in chronological order
since it's a 10-year process of all the
people who have helped me over the years
my mom and my dad Beth Chapman and dr.
Dudley D Chapman I I love you I don't
see where you are I think you're over
here somewhere okay I am so thankful to
you for believing in me when things
didn't seem like they were panning out
this is a testimony to perseverance
everyone everyone it doesn't matter if
you're a filmmaker doesn't matter what
you do if you have something in your
heart and it is pressing you you keep
going because now I'm standing up at the
Academy yeah and to have your family and
friends around you who encourage you it
is everything and I have to continue to
thank my aunt Pat and my entire family
who's over here and jada jada in triva
my church family that's over there to
the people who first helped me get to
Haiti when I started doing this Jay
lamothe Tiffany Steen Marilyn Payne the
peen family the DeSousa family my Rhodes
family they didn't help me to get to
Haiti but they are my husband's family
and I love them thank you my mentors at
USC michael taylor bruce block Michael
Fink Brenda Goodman Dean Daley and all
of the faculty who are here today who
really encouraged me and believed in me
on the cine Institute in Haiti which is
one of the best film schools it's the
only film school in Haiti right now but
now you see how they can help make an
Academy winning film so please continue
to support them my co-producer Victor
for sale well you guys just wait yes my
co-writer Yasmin yola's are you my love
my editor Jeremy didn't know my DP King
my ding
my you guys I obviously you see I have a
lot of people so I'm not going to go
through all the names my executive
producers and actress who played the
villainous character in there she is the
sweetest thing it's like the nicest
people play the greatest villain sir
Garcelle Beauvais and Lisa L Wilson for
believing in me and lifting me up on
their shoulders and telling me to reach
higher I thank you so so much I also
have to thank their loving friend Jamie
Foxx who have yet to meet okay who also
believed in women filmmakers and I have
to say this is the time we are seeing
some great changes and as a community
men women just internationally people of
color people everyone we're coming
together and we're you can see the
positive changes that are happening in
the Academy they are directly reflected
in the student Academy Awards look at
the diversity of these fantastic
filmmakers and I am so thankful that we
all are working together for positive
change it is it moves me so much Marcel
Jones Howard green Ephraim Walker who
helped connect me to these lovely ladies
Pablo Bryan I know I messed up your name
I'm trying I really am but who did the
beautiful music Jimmy Jean Louie Jasmine
Jean the weak here they are that my
babies they're the stars of the movie to
their mother Evelyn who let me borrow
them and take them to Haiti to Lourdes
okay I just want to thank my entire crew
who's here today and anyone who's here
from Lalo's house who supported donated
helped painted whatever could you please
stand up so I can
I love you and thank you and to the
Haitian community who has supported us
and believed in us and most importantly
to my husband Brian Vincent roads
hey you five bang I love you so much I
am so proud of you
we met at the University of Southern
California Thank You USC tuition is
worth it
and to Sean Hector
Randy Greg everybody at the Academy who
has made this happen who get who's given
us a platform to show that child
trafficking human trafficking is a real
thing and it is not just a Haitian issue
it is a global issue and it is right
here and it's something that we all need
to be concerned about and I'm just so
grateful that you gave us this
opportunity to have this platform and I
just love you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay the last one tonight and the gold
medal winner for narrative film is
spring flower by Giselle another
University of California
[Music]
I know my mom won't remember me to stand
straight right now
my words are yeah I might okay thanks to
Academy for giving me this upward first
I want to thank my cast and crew and a
big thanks to my family thank you so
much for hardly supporting and believing
in me and even acted in my film
my grandma is the act the other is she's
83 yourself than this this is her first
time acting in a film I also want to
thank my school University of Southern
California where I started my dream the
last but not the least I want to thank
my mentor Michael who know a professor
Richard Burton and other faculties for
supporting me and I was not very
confident girl before but they always
encouraged me and helped me to ask me to
tell stories from my heart and after
many screenings many people find me tell
me I like your story and I want to hear
what happens next maybe some of them now
tell choose but I will take the
advantage to become more brave and tell
more story from my two hearts I hope you
can touch more people the whole series
our to go over the past
a sin father/son summer season you're so
dirty sure
sorry no sir
[Music]
congratulations everybody's winners all
the winners tonight thank you for these
just drop-dead gorgeous beautiful films
so before you leave here tonight I ask
you to think for a moment not just about
what you have received but about what
you still have to give because most of
all tonight we ask you to believe to
believe that together your generation
will share an awesome journey to help
lift up millions through the power of
film so keep writing keep producing art
keep taking us to places we never
imagined and only dream only you could
dream of
and keep believing that because of your
creativity and conscience in your heart
someone somewhere when they least expect
it but both but most needed will
recognise their own reflection in your
vision because of your gift someone
somewhere will stand a little taller
think a little differently about their
neighbor walk a difficult road with more
certainty winners all yours is a gift
not a gift to display on your mantle or
rest in your trophy case but a gift to
share with the world so student Academy
Award recipients go light up the world
you guys thank you and good night
miss worldwide